Hey guys finally got a haircut.
Jared here,
after 14 years of patiently waiting,
we finally got to see the incredibles
two and it pretty much shattered all the
predictions we made on our movie.
Podcasts showed me the meaning.
Now as the movie,
good.
Yes,
well,
we expected that,
but what surprised us is just how
thoughtful the film is and it all has to
do with the films villain screen slaver
not only to screen slaver Dole out some
majorly relevant commentary on the
effects of our culture's obsession with
screens,
but her presence Mike just make the
incredibles two the most subversive
superhero movie ever made.
So welcome to this wisecrack quick take
on the incredibles two and watch out a
monster amount of spoilers ahead,
but as always,
first a quick recap.
Helen gets recruited by media mogul,
Winston Devers,
new PR campaign is goal change the
public face of supers in order to reform
their image and eventually changed the
laws that outlawed them.
Meanwhile,
Mr incredible has to take over parenting
duties,
which means helping violet through her
boy drama and trying to contain Jack.
Jack's mind boggling new powers as the
PR blitz kicks off,
Helen's job quickly takes her face to
face with screen slaver who literally
uses computers and television screens to
control people like a Jedi mind trick
with a film degree.
Here's the fundamental theme at the core
of the films conflict that in the
digital age perception has supplanted
reality.
Early on,
Winston introduces us to this idea when
he explains the real reason that
superheroes were outlawed.
Public perception was against them
because people associated superheroes
with the crime scenes they superhero
dad.
He argues that in order to change the
law,
first we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes.
Essentially Winston's pitch is that the
image of supers as communicated by the
media is more real than their lived
experience.
Thus,
Winston thinks that changing the public
perception of supers rather than
changing any of their actual deeds is
essential to getting the ban lifted.
So his plan is to create a specially
curated reality of supers to be consumed
by the American people.
How will he do this?
By sticking a camera in Helen super suit
and making her both a walking virtual
reality machine and a serious
competition to twitch.
From there,
we meet the villains.
Screensaver later revealed to be Evelyn
mind controlling a pizza delivery guy.
Everyone's motivation is actually a
rather sophisticated critique of
mindless media consumption and how it
makes people passive participants in
their own lives.
She gives a truly epic monologue in
which she complained about the way how
everything meaningful must be packaged
into talk shows,
game shows,
travel shows,
etc.
Gc supers as an essential part of that
media landscape and that they offer a
security and comfort that keeps the
masses docile.
Now,
this is where our philosophy census
started tinGling the plot of
inCredibles.
Two is a neon sign pointing to
philosopher slash guy.
We'd like to mention a lot the genre
baudrillard who wrote about the power of
screens to influence our opinions and
indeed control our lives.
In his book screened out,
he argues that video interactive screens
and virtual reality have brought us into
a state of perpetual interactivity where
there's no longer any separation between
the media we consume and lives we lead.
If anything,
he argues the virtual reality of the
internet,
tv,
and video games seems more real than the
world we inhabit and even supersedes
reality.
Both winston and evelyn take this theory
and run with it in very different ways.
Each is trying to use the mediated
image.
I eat the perception of superheroes to
change reality.
I belong.
Baudrillard says that the real aim of
media consumption is to hide or
disappear into the virtual.
An idea that evelyn's goggles and
screens exaggerate to great effect by
hypnotizing people into a fugue state in
which they are completely detached from
the real world.
In this way,
the film warns about the harmful power
of screens to control our lives.
the immersive power of helen's pov crime
fighting videos create exactly the kind
of absorbing media bosure discusses.
That's why they're so effective and
immediately start shifting public
opinion.
Also,
it's good for plot development.
helen's emo of saving people from bad
guys hasn't changed a bit,
but now that people can see her bravery
up close,
it's suddenly more real at times.
The movie isn't too subtle about any of
this.
At one point,
evelyn and helen debate like drunk
philosophy majors about whether the
selling of the product I the mediated
image of it is more important than the
product itself.
Now they can't come to a solid
conclusion,
which seems fair because modern
philosophers can't either and they've
had thousands of pages of writing on
which to try.
Of course,
we later learned that evelyn's beef with
superheroes is less egg heady and more
personal.
WheN burglars broke into her family's
home,
her father counted on his superhero
buddies to save him.
Instead of using his safe room,
he was shot dead.
And as a result,
she now blamed superheroes for her
father's passed city and clear inability
to think logically in high pressure
situations.
So she decides to use the very thing she
despises the image of supers to destroy
their viability and importance to her.
Not only do screens make us passive
observers in our own lives,
but the image of superheroes on those
screens does something similar.
The images of benevolent,
all powerful beings,
perhaps primus,
to believe like evelyn's dad,
that our problems will be solved by
strong altruistic individuals,
but wait a second,
aren't we to watching the incredibles?
Two,
a superhero movie through a screen and
see,
this is where the film gets potentially
very subversive.
Are we not also participating in this
same vicarious hero worship when we
watched in awe as the incredible saved
the day on the flashy silver screen?
So what are we supposed to think of
watching a superhero movie that
criticizes the effects of selling
superheroes?
do mediated images?
Well,
ultimately the ending is pretty
comforting to fans.
Be incredible.
Stop screen slaver supers are made legal
again by some sort of un knockoff and
evelyn is carted off by the police,
but just when everything is about to be
wrapped up nice and neat.
Violet,
who's third power is apparently sarcasm
immediately jumps in to cast doubt on
our happy ending saying,
I'm sorry that she's super rich and will
only get like two years in jail,
so should the incredible saving the city
from that giant yachts,
warpath convinced us that everything's
all good,
or is brad bird pointing at something
more sinister with violence?
Final quip is he suggesting that viewing
such an uplifting ending brought by the
hands of almighty benign superheroes
might make us feel satisfied even
pacified when in reality,
whatever that is,
there are still many injustices that
need to be addressed,
but what do you guys think?
Is this the first superhero movie to
promote a critical view on the effects
of superhero movies?
Let us know what you guys think in the
comments and hey,
if you like geeking out about what may
be pixar smartest franchise,
as much as we do,
you've got to check out our friends over
at cinema winds.
They just broke down everything awesome
about the first incredible and it's
incredible and even if you've seen the
incredibles about 10 times like I have,
I guarantee that by watching this video,
you're gonna learn something new about
why this movie is awesome and that's
what cinema winds is all about.
It's not about subjecting these movies
to a level of literalism that they
weren't built for.
It's all about appreciation and it's not
even just about appreciating the surface
level stuff.
These guys are really smart,
they're really insightful.
They dig deep,
and I promise that if you love the
incredibles,
you'll only love it more.
After watching this video.
And if you guys want another video to
check out,
I recommend their video on thor
ragnarok.
I'm a big fan of thor ragnarok.
I really loved the director and after
watching their video,
I only loved it even more so.
If you love movies and love to love
them,
even more cinema winds is the place for
you.
So click here to check out their channel
and tell wise cracks.
Sent you.
Thanks a lot guys,
and as always,
pee.